what's up everyone don't worry it's not
just me
today we have a very special guest
two of my favorite guys
in the world
uh most recently uh hired as co-pilots
for the Pacific Rim project everybody
make some noise for Jay and Trey of the
random mortar podcast come on out here
boys
[Laughter]
oh man oh man
I hate shaking your hands dude yeah I
got a little egg drip on there yeah this
cause like look at the center of my son
off to school yeah dad you got this [__]
I'm gonna study hard Cody's a little
late
um where's he at if you if you missed
last week's episode Cody was on
just now uh like a seven day hike or
something I forget how many days but he
was out there off grid all right I said
this earlier but he went on the Drake
concert of hikes mad exclusive you have
to buy tickets they got merch
um I think so oh [__] God damn
dang
welcome to the show bro
he did that whole hike in designer wow
okay yeah dripped out yeah yeah you got
dumb boots hurt out there sorry it's
been a long week yeah it was just a bear
attack what's going on here
well funny you say
so last last week do you want to tell
him yeah
we were right
we were making fun of bears
brown bears no black bears yeah oh yes
because they're supposed to be
wasn't supposed to be a racial thing
honestly I'm blind to the color
I don't see bear color man I'm blind to
Bear's colors
okay all right I just know it was the
violent type of bear
is he allowed to push it on his shirt
regardless of what color it was yeah
yeah yeah yeah so what colors
[Laughter]
all right we can't do this
I had a feeling does it happen
why I gotta be the black bear man be
right here man in scientific term for
them I guess we're kind of panda bears
my over a little bit you know we got
that mixture
yeah regardless it's 9 A.M you know I
just woke up it's too early for racism
man too early for racism for some people
it's it's not early enough you know oh
you're right yeah yeah some people this
is the most racist podcast yeah it is
yeah yeah you're on it right now go in
oh I know I don't get the pamphlet
so whoever you hate man just let it out
you know oh [__] yeah that's right
at what point in the YouTube video can
the racism start I don't know that's a
good point I think it's 45 seconds you
gotta wait 45 seconds
like guys cool it for the advertisers
all right you could be a racist those
pictures
anyways I did I fought a bear
I couldn't remember what color it was
but oh okay
um this happened so fast they were
really pissed about what we said yeah so
Cody was basically
Cody was saying they're not [__] Bears
yeah black ones yeah because they're
supposed to be like they're supposed to
be the nicer one the cuddly the black
ones yeah
no Brown lay down no Brown what was it
saying brown black black get attacked
black you get an attack no no it's what
was it black fight back Brown stay down
black fight back you can take a black
one you can't take a brown one you're
[__] so racing you could take anyone
no I just remember yeah I was saying
well I mean like basically I ran into we
were like making fun of black bears yeah
saying they're like yeah we were saying
they were kind of a little soft yeah
cuddly right give me those I saw Black
Bear Once in Vancouver yeah right give
me that same Vibe yeah
I met one in the wild
and it did not appreciate that yeah it
heard what we said yeah yeah and so I
remember the phrase black fight back and
so I
I fought back
and uh it was pretty traumatic
pretty violent yeah as I was kind of
getting mauled and trying to fight for
my life out there
I got a picture
of the bear yeah but I'm warning you
it's super [__] graphic okay check it
out oh
what do you mean that's a that's a scary
what are you talking about man what's
the scale this is a large bike this is a
large bike
now what's the size of this bicycle nah
man you can't trust them you can't trust
them at any size you know bear is bare I
feel that wow oh yeah all of them yeah
on this one yeah
because you know they got a low center
of gravity so they down here
you can't you know what I mean you ever
met a vicious Chihuahua yeah bro your
shins are finished probably would be
hard to fight them no it'd be an even
fight for us yeah for us would be fine
man-to-man
you guys aren't sure about you guys like
medium and [__] Yeah medium yeah thanks
man yeah I appreciate it it's a good
medium yeah normal medium extra medium
you guys are like
I think the top three tallest ever be on
set
yeah rats who's on top who's at the top
of the charts Hassan was the only other
tall person we had no Mr Beast is pretty
tall isn't he he's decent he ain't
beasting though yeah like we Beast yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm actually putting out
a challenger facing one-on-one for like
five million
but he put up the money though
just one-on-one in anything would You
Bet Your Life on that a ball game yeah
how nice is he I don't I mean he's a
nice guy
I'll do about five milligans Mr Beast
what about you think you fight him
whoa
yeah I gotta see his back muscles first
let's see if he really beast in
no but he looks normal you got like a
normal body yeah
you ever see those guys work out like
forever but they're just normal yeah
yeah it's like why are you in the gym
you've been doing so many other things
do you remember what you were just
saying you definitely remember you were
just saying
what was the audio the audio did not uh
no I was just saying something racist
yeah the audio did not cut and you
remember exactly what you were saying
just a second ago Trey shirt always
looked like that oh yes I um got coffee
done yeah is that like I think is I
don't know if it was a prank on you guys
to give me a cup without the lid on it
it was a print we like to do that yeah
yeah yeah I thought we were all
Canadians in here boys oh wow
you just told me I'm not from real
Canada yeah literally right there
we all know where it is
it's not it's not put back they didn't
want to be there it's definitely not
Quebec yeah Manitoba what's going on we
got you know I forgot Manitoba they got
movies
Nature's probably like hell there no
Nature's probably nice and [__] oh no
where are you from Calgary yeah it's
probably nice y'all got wheat and [__]
I've never been there no we infiltrated
American entertainment yeah who Canada
yeah yeah we put Seth through we got our
boy JC there yeah Jim Carrey uh who else
Nathan Fielder Seth Myers he's getting
busy yeah yeah we're tearing us out
there drinking yeah JB's JB the weekend
yeah Travis Scott
[Laughter]
yeah
Steve Harvey
[Laughter]